(chime)
(keyboard keys clacking)
(eerie music)
(chime)
(keyboard keys clacking)
(door closing sound effect)
(eerie music)
- [Cat Voiceover] That's dumb.
Don't ignore the shadows
that lurk in the corner of your eye.
They're watching you.
The ancient Greeks called them Shades.
In Korea, the phenomenon
is called "gawi nulim"
which means to be pressed down by a ghost.
Some believe these shadowy creatures
are inter-dimensional
beings who are studying us
for reasons unknown.
I didn't believe in any of these myths,
but the fact that others
had experienced what I had
made it more real to--
(door opens)
- Geez-o-pete, Cat,
it's one in the morning!
What are you doing up?
- Reading.
- Don't get smart with me, missy.
10 more minutes.
- Fine.
(yawns)
- [Cat Voiceover] I was 15
when I started seeing shadows
in my peripheral vision.
My parents got divorced
and my mom and I moved
from DC to Roanoke, Virginia.
I had a hard time
sleeping in the new place.
I was afraid of how quiet it was.
I was afraid of the
seemingly endless woods
that surrounded my house.
But, mainly, I was afraid
that when I laid in bed
at night I wasn't alone.
I couldn't see it at first,
but I could feel its presence.
Like a low frequency hum
vibrating just under my skin.
And then one night I saw it,
A dark void in the shape of a human.
I tried to get up, but I couldn't move.
I tried to scream, but nothing came out.
It crawled over me,
brought its face to mine
and then--
(door opens)
(screams)
- Serves you right.
Go to bed or I'm taking the computer.
- Don't you ever knock?
- Come on, sweetie, go to bed.
It's late.
Okay, goodnight.
- Goodnight, jeez.
(crickets chirping)
(ghostly mumbling)
(heavy breathing)
(crickets chirping)
(eerie music)
(ghostly chant)
(static)
(forced stammering)
(heavy breathing)
(low frequency rumbling)
- [Shadow] Kiss
me.
(intense high pitch)
(birds chirping)
(scoffs)
- [Woman] Did you leave this on all night?
I'm not made of money, you know?
If you're not up in 30 minutes
I'm dragging you out of bed.
(intense music)
(silent mouthing)
(intensifying music)
(menacing music)